RUMEN DANGOVSKI: Hi, everybody.
I'm Rumen, and today I'll
talk about three things:
optical trapping, the Boltzmann
constant, and Brownian motion.
The goal of the
lab is to extract
Boltzmann's constant
out of Brownian motion
and there are two key
components to think about.
First one is the
Boltzmann's constant,
which is prevalent in
different types of science.
For example, we can
have it in biophysics
where people use the Boltzmann's
constant to try to understand
forces in a cellular level.
We have it in thermodynamics
with the famous equipartition
theorem.
How does this relate
to the Brownian motion?
The key thing is to think
about length scales.
Brownian motion is relevant
in terms of microns.
And at the same time, if you
look at a cellular level,
for example, if we
look at our hair,
we have micron-sized hair.
All right.
So there are different ways
to measure the Boltzmann's
constant.
Some people measure the
speed of sound in argon gas,
others do optical
trapping in air.
We will do slightly
different optical trapping,
as you will see,
but the consensus
among the scientific community
is that it is challenging.
Our plan is to prepare
Brownian particles
and control their
Brownian motion.
We take spherical
glass beads of diameter
of 3.2 microns and
the main tool is
to concentrate a highly-focused
lasers on top of these beads.
There's interesting
physics going on:
light carries momentum
thus it generates force.
We have that the net
gradient force opposes
the motion of the beam while the
net scattering force goes along
the motion of the beam.
And when these two forces
balance each other,
we have a bead that
is at the center.
When you push this bead
a little bit to the left
or to the right, then we have
that the gradient forces are
pulling me back in the
center and essentially we
observe a simple
harmonic motion.
In a more concrete example,
what we did is we took samples
and we confined everything
into a two-dimensional plane.
This is very important.
We have two directions:
the x direction
and the y direction
for the beads.
We put them into water and
a source of Brownian motion
comes from the collisions
between our bead
with the molecules
into the water.
These are thermal collisions
that generate Brownian motion.
As you can see, this lonely
bead has it's Brownian motion.
What's interesting is when we
shine light on top of a bead,
we trap this bead and we
can find the Brownian motion
so it's feasible to
measure the motion.
And the theory behind
this is very beautiful.
It's about the
equipartition theorem,
which relates the
kinetic energy coming
from the simple harmonic
motion on the left hand side
with the thermal energy due
to the degrees of freedom.
Now let us recall that we have
a two-dimensional confinement
so we have a direction
in x and direction in y.
So it means that in
each of the directions,
we have one degree
of freedom, which
is correlated with this
equipartition theorem.
Now an interesting thing
about the statistical motion
of the molecules is that we
have the simple harmonic motion.
However, the things
are moving into water
so there is a drag
force that dominates.
So we simplified
the left hand side.
What is very interesting
is the f factor, which
comes from the collisions
between the bead
with the molecules, this
generates forcing and driving
of the simple harmonic motion.
I would like to
point out one thing
about the scales of the forces.
We have piconewtons, which is
relevant for optical trapping
and for Brownian motion.
This is the first
observation that we did,
and actually Einstein did this
observation a long time ago.
He observed the white noise--
essentially the
collisions-- they
generate uncorrelated forcing.
And we can think
of it as something
that is not biased
with any distribution,
it's just uniform.
As you can see on
these slides, we
have the position
plotted in terms of time
and it exhibits a uniform
distribution of the spectrum.
Another thing that I
would like to point out
is to look at this plot of
fluctuations in x and y,
and the power which is linear
with the current of the lasers.
As you can see, as
the power becomes big,
this means that we
are trapping more
so we have less fluctuations,
which is something as expected.
All right, so let's
figure out what
we want to do with this lab.
We have the
equipartition theorem
and essentially we
have three components
that we would like to measure
in order to extract Kb.
We need to find the
fluctuations, which I just
presented to you.
We need to find a stiffness
coefficient, alpha,
which is related to the
spring constant of motion.
And then we need to
measure the temperature, t.
The apparatus that we use
has two main components.
The two components are concerned
with two types of light
that we use in our experiment.
We use a laser
that shines on top
of the confined
two-dimensional samples
and tries to trap a bead.
The scattered light from
the laser goes into a QPD--
a quadrant photo detector--
which is an
ultra-fast camera that
manages to quickly
digitalize the content
and give us the position
of the scattered light.
So when we trap
the bead, we know
where it is by observing
the feedback from the QPD.
The other interesting
part of the apparatus
is the LED light, which
illuminates the sample
and then it brings
it to the CCD camera,
and this is very important.
So the CCD camera is very slow.
It cannot measure
Brownian motion.
What it can do is it can
tell us where are the beads.
It can allow us to
look at the water
and find the beads
we want to trap.
So these two components
in combination
are crucial for the
success of our research.
There is interesting
electronics coming behind this.
Essentially, the
signals from the QPD
and from the stage position
where we put our sample
are given in terms of volts.
So a natural
question that arises
is how are we going to
remember what is important?
There are two important
things that we
like to keep track
of, two positions.
The first one is the
position of the stage
that gives us a relative
point of consideration.
And the second one
is the position
of the QPD, which,
as you can recall,
it measures the place of the
bead that we have trapped.
These inputs are given
in terms of volts,
so the natural thing
to do is to find
the calibration that
converts these volts
into actual distances.
Here you can see how we do this.
We plot the stage x position--
we can plot the stage y,
it's completely analogous to
the QPD the positions here.
And the conversion factor
hides along the slopes here.
As you can see, we have
two different slopes here
with different absolute values,
so this type of measurement
is prone to errors.
How we approach this
problem is that we
fault by choosing
more data points
and trying to increase the
statistic thus hopefully
reducing the systematics
of this measurement.
The second step is to start
getting the components
that we need in
order to extract kb
is to measure the stiffness
coefficient alpha.
Now the main idea is to
take the equation of motion
and to make a
[? free entrance ?]
from in order to get
the positions in terms
of frequencies.
There is mathematics behind
this and essentially, the power
spectral distribution,
and that's
the distribution
of this motion here
that we expect obtains
this form here.
From where we can extract
the characteristic frequency,
F naught, and F
naught gives us alpha,
which is what we really need.
This is a log log plot,
as you can see here.
Another thing I
would like to mention
is look at the
proportionality here.
As we increase
the power, we also
increase the stiffness
coefficient alpha
because we're
trapped more closely,
so it means that F
naught has to increase.
And indeed, when we
increase the power,
we are shifting F
naught to the right.
Having all of these
components, we
can put this into
the big picture.
And the big picture is the
extraction of kb over here.
I showed you x squared,
the fluctuations.
I showed you alpha.
We can measure the temperature,
t, and then we can get kb.
The essence of
this measurement is
to look at the inverse
proportionality
between fluctuations and
the trapped stiffness.
Then we can make a fit with
a reasonable chi-squared
probability, and from
here we can extract kb.
The result is
presented on the slide.
We also show you the
measurement that we
extract from literature.
Our result is within 2 sigma
of the accepted value of kb.
Actually we're very close to
one sigma from the accepted
value of a kb.
What is driving this
unfortunate outcome?
The thing that drives
this unfortunate outcome
is the systematic
errors on our picture.
This is our starting error.
This is the uncertainty in kb.
And there are different factors
that contribute to this.
As you saw, the calibration
is very difficult.
We have error from the
laser hitting the water
and changing the temperature.
We have systematic error of the
electronics, which we safely
ignore because the first
two factors dominate this.
Our electronics
were very precise.
And then we have the
statistical uncertainties
that we use which correspond to
some error propagating tricks.
OK, now let's do
our investigation.
The first one is
about the calibration.
As you can see, all of these
slopes should be valid,
but they're actually not.
So what we do is we take them
into account, we average them,
then we take more data
points, we average again,
and then we propagate
errors in order
to reduce the systematics.
The second one is due to
the heating of the laser.
Essentially what happens is
when the laser hits the water,
it starts heating the vicinity.
And this is unfortunate
because yes, we
can measure the room temperature
by using the thermometer,
but actual uncertainty
on the temperature
is much bigger because we have
extra heating due to the laser.
We tried diligently
to avoid this
by moving the laser
constantly so that it doesn't
stay in one place
and heat up a lot,
but it's very hard to quantify
how exactly it heats up
the water.
And the third one is
concerned with our fit
with the fluctuations in terms
of the trapped stiffness.
Initially, when we did the
fit with the PSD method,
we get a probability of
chi squared equals zero.
And then we quickly
realized that essentially
what we need to do is take into
account the horizontal errors.
And here what we do is we
transform the horizontal errors
into the vertical errors.
And this thing we can do by
using addition in quadrature
and propagation of
the errors, which
gave us a reasonable
realistic Chi squared of 0.33.
In conclusion, I'll
start with limitations.
As you saw, it's very
hard to distinguish
between systematic errors and
statistical uncertainties.
The reason for this
is, as you saw,
is that we are fighting
with the systematics
by introducing more statistics
and everything mixes up
in the propagation of errors.
The second thing that was
very difficult in this lab
is that we need to move
the laser constantly.
So one of the people
working on this lab
has to keep track of
where the laser is
and whether you're
trapping things
that you may not want to trap.
The third thing is
the need to find
better ways of calibration.
And there are people who are
actively working on this topic
here.
As you saw, the
main source of error
came from the
calibration, actually.
But the plus is that we can
give a reasonable estimate
to Boltzmann constant
and at the same time,
we can have a lot of
fun while doing so.
I'd like to thank
to my partner Emma.
And I think collaboration
is very important for JLab
and more specifically for
this particular experiment.
This experiment is impossible
to be done without a partner
because it's very difficult.
It's very difficult
to keep track of where
you want to put the laser
and also what is going
on around the laser.
While one of the people
is moving the laser,
the other one should be
looking at the CCD camera
and telling where are
we going and what are we
actually trapping?
What do we want to avoid?
Like we don't want these
guys in our picture.
I would also like
to thank the staff
of this class for
their useful feedback
and their valuable help.
And finally, for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So in
this experiment, we
found it useful to consider
the trap being elliptical
rather than circular.
And so it strengthens
alpha, being
different in the x
and y directions,
did you do that in
your calculation?
RUMEN DANGOVSKI: Yeah,
so we have a lot of this
should be trapped stiffness
versus this is the current.
And here, actually I
haven't shown that.
The trapped stiffness
differs whether you
are looking in the x
direction or the y direction.
The actual measurements
are analogous because
the mathematics is the same.
But as you can see here, we
have different data points
for the two cases.
We account this into
our considerations, yes.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
earlier that [INAUDIBLE]
with air or in air [INAUDIBLE].
Is there any benefit-- or
what's the main difference
between [INAUDIBLE]?
RUMEN DANGOVSKI:
Everything boils down
to this consideration here.
Let me just find my explanation.
It boils down to the
viscosity that dominates.
So in our case, we have
the viscosity of water
that dominates.
When you look in
different mediums,
you might have different
types of viscosities
which would change the motions.
So I have the paper,
I didn't actually
read through the whole
details of how exactly
the mathematics
changes, probably does.
Also probably another issues
that may not arise or may arise
is the laser, like in this case.
The laser heats up
the water, but I
don't know how exactly the
laser would react with the air.
Maybe it's going to
heat up a little bit,
but how is this heat going
to be distributed in space?
I'm not very knowledgeable
of this as of now.
PROFESSOR: Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Right there,
what does it say?
Only one degree of
freedom [INAUDIBLE]??
RUMEN DANGOVSKI: So the
equipartition theorem,
it breaks into components.
It breaks into the
component of x,
where you have one
degree of freedom,
and it breaks into
the component of y,
where you have another
degree of freedom.
Each of these considerations
is concerned only
within one movement.
AUDIENCE: So you have
two degrees of freedom?
RUMEN DANGOVSKI: OK, well, you
can think about it in this way.
We have two degrees
of freedom in total,
but in the actual
directions that
are useful for our
considerations,
we have only one
degree of freedom.
AUDIENCE: You said you
were using the 3.2 micron
[INAUDIBLE].
There were other
sizes available.
It looks like some
of your photographs
from the [INAUDIBLE].
Did you try data from both the
small beads and the big beads?
Curious how they
compared in quality.
RUMEN DANGOVSKI:
This is 3.2 microns.
Later on, you saw
the one microns.
I think our data is concerned
with the 3.2 microns.
My results are not related
with the one micron.
We just played with
it and tried this.
We also tried trapping
cells from onions.
It was very fun to play
with, but unfortunately, we
couldn't get any valuable
quantitative results there.
So even though it's quite a
lot of fun, we have some clips,
it's not worth for
this presentation,
which concentrates on the kb.
[APPLAUSE]